whoopi goldberg
is very upset
by the prospect of overruling roe v wade
and planned parenthood bkc and she took
to her panel of cackling hens on the
view
to voice
her
main arguments against
the very real
possibility
that roe will be overturned
do any of you men
have any eggs or the possibility of
carrying a fetus how dare you talk about
what a fetus wants you have no idea
now i'm
i'm fine if you disagree with abortion i
have no problem with that my problem
comes when you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you
so a lot of confusion and problems with
whoopi's pseudo argument here the fir
the first one is she just hasn't caught
up to this because she's a liberal from
decades ago and not a liberal from today
meaning she still thinks that the
argument
men can't have babies and so men can't
have an opinion on abortion she thinks
that still is coherent in the new
leftist view of the world but the new
leftist view of the world is a
transgender view of the world in which
we are told that men can have babies and
can have a uterus and do have eggs so
that part is going to fall flat with
some of the younger viewers but the
cackling boomer hens who are watching
the show they will they will love that
then uh she moves on and she does this
thing that liberals do and i bet it's
sincere but it's so stupid which is she
says look i have no problem
okay if you oppose abortion that's fine
that's true i'm so open-minded i respect
your opinion
but the minute that you
do anything about that
the minute you let your view of abortion
affect anything in your life or the
outer world then i've got a big problem
with it
i don't i don't mind if you have that
view so long as you keep it trapped in
your head and never never allow that to
uh to express itself in in public life
how dare you
men
and pro-lifers how dare you how dare i
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first though
get
physical gold
i know when i say that it sounds like
i'm paris hilton just just wearing one
of those tank tops that says stop being
poor you know get physical gold michael
you get physical physical gold's
expensive what if i told you you can
start getting physical gold for as
little as 30 a month you'd probably call
me a liar but hold on acre has figured
out how for just 30 a month you can
subscribe to their gold bars when your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars they discreetly ship acre gold
to your house
if you want to up the ante you can
subscribe to their new 100 a month 5
gram gold bar which is terrific acres
letting you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
they keep you updated on your gold stash
every month and then they'll ship when
you hit the price threshold
it's a really great way to start getting
involved in physical precious metals
which i've loved investing in and
especially acre gold go to get acre gold
dot com slash noel start investing in
physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that's
getacregold.com
knowles
how dare i i would i will tell you how i
dare
i am a citizen so i have rights at least
in theory to
participate in the government of this
country
i have a brain i have faculties of
reason so i can tell that a baby is a
baby that a baby is a unique
human life from the moment of conception
and i have a conscience
at least some something of a functioning
conscience
so i know that it's wrong to kill
innocent humans
that is how i dare
those three things
self-government the ability to perceive
the world with at least some degree of
accuracy
and the ability to make moral judgments
that's that's the same way that whoopi
dare make some arguments
except
she is denying my right as a citizen she
is neglecting
and trying to deny the
scientific reality of the baby
and she is
obtusely ignoring the moral reality of
killing a baby
that's how now there's
kind of a deeper
aspect to whoopi's stupid remarks which
is
she says how do you
know what the fetus wants
right the fetus the unborn baby is not
conscious
that the baby could not
tell you what the baby wants like this
morning i was having breakfast with my
baby my baby is almost 11 months old but
he's still not really talking he says
mama and dada and he didn't like what we
had for breakfast and all he wanted to
do was eat blueberries
i wish that i could ask my little baby
hey little baby what what do you want to
have for breakfast instead but he can't
articulate his wands
and he's an 11 month old baby
really a 20 month old baby when you
factor in the nine months that he was
gestating so surely a six month old baby
in the womb can't articulate what it
wants so how do you know what the baby
wants how do you know the baby doesn't
want to be murdered in the womb and then
scooped out by some psycho doctor how do
you know that
i actually do know that the baby doesn't
want that
the way that i know that is because in
my understanding of the world which is
the traditional understanding of the
world that crafted our country and our
entire civilization
man has a proper end
there is a purpose to life
there is uh
the leftist ears tumbler is for drinking
leftist tears out of
delicious the leftist tears tumbler is
not for hitting a baseball the leftist
tears tumbler is not for writing a novel
that's not its proper end and man has a
proper end too and society has a proper
end too and we can know actually what is
good for people and we can know what
leads to flourishing and we can know
what is just and right
and in the radical subjectivist world of
whoopi goldberg and i don't mean to just
single out her and the view and all
these libs who are making these
arguments you can't know the proper end
of man and so it's all just willfulness
and if we want to kill the baby how dare
you tell me that i'm not allowed to
pursue my will ring that bill
please
thank you i appreciate it that way
you'll get notifications if you don't
get notifications you want to also
subscribe to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knoll show leave a five star
review if you don't mind
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]